[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES BYERS: Welcome
to CST101, which
is Organizing Your Resources
for Cost Management on GCP.
Hopefully, you've all had lunch.
If you haven't, I apologize
for the taunting donut
truck prominently featured
in several slides.
Sorry in advance.
There will be no donut truck.
But hopefully we'll give you
some great ideas about how
to manage your costs on GCP.
So as a reminder, this session
has Dory, our internal Q&A
system linked out of the
Next '19 app on your phones.
So if you have
questions or you want
to see what other people are
asking as we go, please fire
up the app, click through, and
you can both vote up questions
and add your own.
Now, today, we are here to
answer one important question
that I think is
relevant to everyone
using GCP from the tiniest
solo developer to the largest
multinational corporation.
The question is,
what is the best
way to structure your resources
in order to understand
and manage cost on GCP?
This is not a question
that you can answer once
on your first day, or
after your first year,
or five years into using GCP.
It's a question I
think you always
have to ask yourself on your
journey in our platform.
And we'll take that
journey together today,
going from tiny to
large, and answer
the question along the way.
Again, a reminder for
those who just joined.
There's a Dory Q&A link
in your app on your phone
if you'd like to ask questions.
We'll also leave lots of time at
the end to take questions live.
So we'll introduce the
concepts we're talking about,
a couple of definitions.
We'll dive into
a "Hello, World!"
I think no cloud presentation
would be right without a little
"Hello, World!"
for the developers
in the audience.
We'll talk about
organizations in GCP, a method
for structuring your resources.
We'll talk about
folders, and we'll
talk about labels and how
those concepts help influence
the design of your
applications, and how
you can use them to do reporting
and reasoning about costs.
We'll also touch on some
more advanced topics
and cross-link over to a
couple of other sessions
that are happening that dive
deeper into customer examples
into the BigQuery
billing export,
into using Data Studio, and
other more advanced tools.
So let's get started.
First, who am I?
I'm James.
I am a product manager
in Google Cloud Billing.
And Cloud Billing
has a mission inside
of Google's larger mission.
Our mission is to make billing
trustworthy, transparent,
simple, and predictable.
And each one of those is
quite important, especially
when you're living in a
world where if you wanted to,
you could have 100,000 cores,
or a whole pile of RAM,
or petabytes of storage.
We really want to make sure
you know exactly what you're
spending, why
you're spending it,
and give you great levers and
tools to manage your workloads.
And we try to do that at
the lowest possible prices.
We have a long history
of driving down
the cost of compute on the
back of Google's innovation
and infrastructure
[? on ?] our scale.
What will you learn?
We'll look at projects in
the context of organizations
and folders.
We'll look at labels for
slicing and dicing cost
across those
projects and folders.
And we'll look at
exports and reports that
help you track and
trace those costs
as you use your workloads,
as you run workloads on GCP.
We're going to start
as a solo developer--
one person, one garage, one dog.
I'm told you have to
have all three, otherwise
the chemistry is just not right.
And we'll go all the way up
to a multinational corporation
with thousands of
employees around the world.
And we'll look at
these tools and how
they apply at each step of
that journey and that growth.
Now, quick, show of hands.
How many here are solo
developers, dog or not?
One person, one computer.
Got one in the back, thank you.
Two.
Awesome.
No dog?
No dog in the bag?
No.
They wouldn't let you.
I know.
How many of you are in a
startup, small company,
just getting going?
About another quarter
of folks here.
Small to medium-sized company?
Somewhere in the middle.
Not a startup.
Not a huge company.
How about a large organization,
big multinational?
About half bringing in the rest.
Great.
OK, great diversity.
And we'll try to answer
these questions for every one
of those types of usage.
We're going to show a couple of
best practices along the way.
You'll see these slides with a
big, bright heading and a best
practice, and we'll summarize
them all at the end.
And of course, this
whole presentation,
both in slide form and
in video, are available
online afterwards.
So don't worry
about taking notes.
A couple of definitions.
We'll talk about organizations,
folders, projects, labels,
and billing accounts.
And I'll dive into
each one of these
so you don't have to
speed read below here.
First, an organization
in the context of GCP
is this top-level parent of
all of your folders, projects,
and resources.
And it's a way to centrally
apply identity, permissions,
and policies across everything
in your organization,
in your own company,
or institution.
And organizations really give
you this level of comfort.
You can apply policy once, you
know it applies everywhere.
They're typically linked
to your company's domain.
So you might have a G Suite
domain, whether or not
you use G Suite services, that's
tied to that organization.
And members of that
domain would have a set
of permissions within GCP.
Organizations contain
folders nested up
to four levels deep,
which are a way
to narrow down those permissions
and policies in a way that
mirrors the structure of
your company, of your teams.
We'll talk more about
that in a moment.
Once we get below orgs, folders,
we get down to projects.
These are the core building
blocks and the place
where workloads live in GCP.
And they're the most
important for us
when we talk about how billing
is structured and reported
in our world.
Just about everything runs
in the context of a project,
and that's the most
important context
you'll see when you're
looking at your costs.
Now, a project can only
live in one folder.
So we have to have a way
to cross-cut and report
across folders, across
projects, anywhere you
want to see that labeled usage.
So our cross-cutting
structure is
called a label, which is
a key value pair, a label
key that you define, and a value
associated with it that you
can attach to a project
or the resources
below the project level.
We'll look at a bunch
of examples about that
in a couple of minutes.
Finally, got to a big
green dollar sign.
A billing account is
this container that
pays for usage within projects.
And a project is always
paid for by a single billing
account in GCP.
Once we have those
basic structures,
we can start to
use them to manage
the visibility of
our costs, seeing
what's happening at
each of those levels,
the accountability,
who's causing spend,
the control to apply
budgets and alerts
and to forecast that spending,
and intelligence to start
to reason about how to
reallocate spending,
how to drive it down,
and how to take control
of costs on our platform.
So this leads us to our
first best practice,
which is the
finest-grained detail you
can get about billing is inside
your BigQuery billing export.
And this is something
you can turn on
for your entire GCP account.
It's worth turning
it on on day one.
It will give you the
most minute detail
we give you about everything
happening in billing.
And we'll look at example
queries and examples
of that export in a
couple of minutes.
All right, we're
into "Hello, World!"
This is where we write
a C program that's
eight lines long that
prints a-- no, I'm kidding.
This is where we talk
about the basics.
One project, one small company.
A startup with their dog.
So we have a billing
account and a single project
sitting under it.
Within that project, we
have some workloads running.
And these might be
familiar to you.
There's many dozens of
services within GCP.
But in this project, we have
Compute Engine, Kubernetes,
Cloud Storage, BigQuery,
and Cloud SQL all running.
And they're all funded
by this one billing
account paying for the one
project they all reside in.
And I've drawn two different
color lines here for a reason.
The green dotted line
on top is pays for.
The billing account pays for all
of the usage within a project.
Separately, the project owns the
resources contained within it.
I drew two color lines
because the permissions
on your billing account and
the permissions on your project
are separate.
You can give a user in your
organization superpowers
on their billing account.
They can be a billing
account administrator
and have full view
of your costs,
but have no control, or
visibility, or access
to any of those resources
within a project.
It's a really important point.
We'll come back
to it again later.
But that's why I have
this vision tests
to see dotted and solid lines.
We'll get rid of the detail
below just for simplicity,
and talk really about billing
accounts and projects.
So you were one developer
with your dog in a bag,
and you've now hired two more.
You hired Bob and Alice.
Bob and Alice are great.
You hired two great developers.
You got lucky.
You found really good ones.
Now, Alice is a
really good coder.
Alice is not super up on
Linux systems administration.
So she ran rm-rf thinking she
was in her home directory.
She wasn't.
She was at the root.
She's wondering why
that's taking so long.
At the same time, Bob here--
Bob is JavaScript like
you can't believe.
But Bob and SQL don't
really get along very well.
He wrote a update query
without a WHERE clause.
He's wondering why that's
taking a long time.
You're wondering maybe about
whether you hired the greatest
Bob and Alice you
could have hired,
but they're going to be OK.
Their faces turn
to frowns as they
realize they've done
something awful in production.
And now we have our first split.
We need a second project.
We need a development
environment,
because Bob and Alice need to
get some guardrails on what
they're doing.
Both projects are funded by the
same single billing account,
but now we can divide
permissions between them.
We can look at the cost of
our production environment.
Might be many times the
size of our dev environment.
And we can put
them in some silos
so they don't blow
away prod again.
This leads us to
another best practice.
Use projects to enforce
boundaries between workloads,
between teams, or
when you really
need to know about the cost
of one set of usage completely
partitioned from another.
A great way to enforce policy.
Now, probably many of you
have multiple projects already
in GCP.
So let's move on.
Let's look at how you actually
see the cost of these projects
and then add some
more complexity
as we grow our company.
The first way you're
going to see these costs
is with your invoice at
the end of the month.
And your invoice tells you
your company, its address,
how much you owe
Google, and some degree
of breakdown about those costs
on a project and resource
level.
The invoice is
great for one thing.
It's great for telling
you how much you owe.
But it's not really
a great cost report.
You can't slice and dice it.
There is both a PDF and a CSV,
and you can slice and dice
the CSV a little bit.
But we'll look at
a much better way
to do those kinds
of questions, rather
than firing up a spreadsheet and
going and querying it that way.
Second tool, billing reports.
Now we're getting to
an interactive way
to slice and dice
cost, and we'll
look at some real
examples sliced and diced
by project, by organization,
by label in a few minutes.
Finally, the BigQuery
billing export.
I mentioned this at the
beginning, this first best
practice.
Really easy to turn
it on, and we'll
look at some real
data in a few minutes
about what you
can get out of it.
To turn on your BigQuery export,
go to your billing account,
click on the
Billing Export link,
and you'll be able to
turn on that export
and put it into a project.
So another best practice.
Use the billing
reports and exports
to answer the why questions.
Use your invoice to reason
about what you owe Google,
that kind of bottom line.
By the way, if your invoice ever
grows beyond 25 pages in a PDF,
we'll start to
collapse it down so we
don't send you the world's
largest PDF to try and open
in your poor web browser.
The CSV version of the invoice
is full detail always, as big
as it gets.
So our startup is growing.
Bob and Alice now have
dozens of teammates,
and we're going to
put an organization
to help manage
policy and control
all of these projects
in our world now.
Probably a best practice
to do from the start,
but the startup
didn't know that,
so they're evolving as they go.
So we've grown.
We have a whole
range of projects.
We decided we wanted to
put a staging environment
in the middle of dev and prod.
We have our MacroService,
that old legacy big old
pile of code somewhere
chugging away.
The founder made a
project called TopSecret.
Don't look there.
There's an archive
for old stuff.
But yay, we're growing
turns into, help,
we're growing when
you start to get
beyond the tens of projects.
Gets hard to reason
about the world.
Gets hard to partition policies,
permissions, and control.
So what can we do here?
Well, first, we're working
on a feature which hasn't yet
launched, but will start
to roll out to customers
later this year to have
one default billing account
for the entire organization.
And when that's
live, you won't have
to reason about billing
accounts on a per-project basis.
You can set it and forget it
at the organization level.
So that's something
that's coming.
Once we get into this
multi-project world,
the same tools
still apply, but you
start to have a need to
filter and slice and dice
to understand costs below
the organization level using
some of the structural concepts
we talked about earlier.
So this is a real
billing report,
and this shows a number of
projects all grouped together.
There's a couple
of other sessions
that go deep into this tool,
but I'll give you the highlights
here today.
Billing reports let
you drill into cost
by the mechanisms
I just described.
And here we have them
broken by project.
So I've opened up this filter
to let me see by project.
I can take those off, and
change how I group and show
cost over time to see what's
growing and what's shrinking.
And obviously,
sometime mid-March, we
ramped up a lot of
usage, and we see
that across all those projects.
I can do a similar kind of
reporting using any of the data
that we have in my
BigQuery billing export.
For those fans of
SQL among us, this
is the 13 lines of SQL that
generated a report grouped
by the project,
which is the project
ID in this column under ID.
The BigQuery billing
export is giving you
very fine-grained
detail on your usage.
So you'll have one row for
each couple of hours of usage
by service, by application,
by project, by label.
And you can query
it as you like.
You can also press that magical
Explore in Data Studio link,
and go out into a world of
visualization and reporting
tools that work incredibly
well with BigQuery.
There are a couple
of other sessions
that go deep with actual
customer examples of that.
We'll talk about that
at the end and I'll
let you know about
those sessions.
The invoice also
ships a CSV, which I
mentioned a couple minutes ago.
For completeness, this
is what it looks like.
You'll see billing
account ID, project name,
what product you're
running, the resource
type, networking versus compute,
IDs, dates, amounts of usage--
the kind of fields you
would expect, but not
at the level of granularity
of our BigQuery export.
So the takeaway
from this section
from a control and
policy perspective,
organizations are for everyone.
They're a great thing to
turn on, whether or not
you use G Suite and
all of the other apps
that sit alongside
in the domain.
Anyone can turn on an org
and its associated identity
as a service for free.
And that's a great
best practice.
Now, we ended our
organization part
being a little bit of trouble.
We had a lot of projects, and
the world was only growing.
And you can start to
see the delineations
where these projects
are really in buckets.
First column is
stages or environments
of our application.
The second column
is our MacroService,
our old legacy stuff
that we broke out.
We've got some acquisitions now.
TopSecret is still there.
Don't mention it.
Archive.
We can put in a layer
of folders to start
to control who can see
each of those resources,
and start to manage the
cost and be able to report
on cost by folder.
And there are different
ways to structure it.
In one form, you can
structure it by environment
if that suits you.
In another form,
you can structure it
by the logical application.
You could structure it by team,
by department, by country.
You're going to align these
folders to how you work
and the structure that makes
the most sense for you.
And you can have a lot of them.
They nest.
You can have as
many folders as you
need to contain your projects.
By the way, you can have
thousands of projects.
No problem.
Platform scales up to
many, many, many thousands.
We have customers with one.
We have customers with
tens of thousands.
So folders mirror how you work,
but they're not the only way
to structure resources, not
the only way to bucket them.
And you can think of them a
little bit like a primary key.
A project can only
be in one folder,
but we need something
else to answer
questions like,
how much should I
spend on databases across this
entire set of applications
and tools?
Tough to answer by folder,
because I have databases kind
of all over the place.
Let's just take the app
folder, and expand that out,
and see how many things are
actually a database here.
Well, I've got some MySQL
servers running on bare metal
GCEs, so to speak.
I've installed them myself.
They don't run in Cloud SQL.
Those are databases.
So let's label those instances
with a key and value.
The key is type.
Value is database.
Now I can do some cross-cutting
reporting within this folder
and across these projects
to see how much I
spent across my databases.
Turns out I got databases
in a lot of other places.
Let's say I add a bunch of
Postgres down in Cloud SQL.
And I have backups in
production, really big ones.
And I want to attribute
those costs to my databases
that they're backups of.
I don't want to confuse
them with other data that's
running in my environment.
So labels on Compute
Engine, labels in Cloud SQL,
labels in Cloud Storage, and
now I can report across them
to roll up cost.
As I mentioned, there
are trade-offs here.
You can think of a folder a
little bit like a primary key.
Each project can live
only in one folder.
They can be nested, but it
can only have one parent.
And you can think of labels
as a set of secondary indexes
on your resources
and on your projects.
It's worth being deliberate
in this design in both cases.
It's worth being really
deliberate in your folder
design, because while it's
easy to move projects around,
it might be disruptive
for policy and permissions
to be shuffling
folders all the time.
In labels, it's worth
thinking about governance,
about the keys that you require
and the values they contain
so that Alice doesn't say
type:DB on a label and Bob says
type:database, and
all of a sudden,
we're living in two
different reporting worlds.
So be deliberate.
Some workloads
will automatically
annotate their resources
with labels for you.
So if you use Deployment Manager
and certain other services
will auto tag resources.
And you can piggyback on those
to do reporting automatically,
and cross-cut.
So what does the
world look like if we
want to cross-cut by label in
these two reporting contexts?
First, in my reporting view,
I can both filter and group
by label.
And here I've done it
with my environment label.
And I've got production,
test, and dev that cross-cut
across all my projects.
There are 18 projects that
are rolled up in this view.
And this is the
usage of those labels
spanning all of those projects.
If I drop into BigQuery,
I can take just
about the same 13 lines
of SQL we saw before,
and I added a little bit more.
So nested field.
So we added a couple of lines
to both un-nest those labels
and to put in a WHERE clause
where we have labels.key
as env.
Now we've cross-cut that
high resolution billing data
by label and we've got a
per-month, per-service cost
for each of those
resources running
across our entire environment.
And of course, that magic
button is still there,
Explore in Data Studio, if
you want to slice and dice
and visualize.
Labels are like
super-charging your reporting.
The way we think about
them as a best practice is
they shouldn't be the end
all, be all of your reporting.
Don't rely
exclusively on labels.
Start with an org.
Put projects in folders.
Use a sensible project layout.
But then when you want to
supercharge, add on this layer,
and you can really
dive deep into cost.
So it's a fantastic way to help
with those gnarly cross-cutting
cases.
Couple of advanced topics, then
we'll leave a good bit of time
for questions.
First, as I mentioned at the
beginning, Billing IAM, Billing
Identity and Access
Management, and Resource IAM,
the roles and permissions on
billing accounts and projects
are completely separate.
You can give your
finance team billing
account admin permissions.
They'll be a super user.
They can run their
queries in BigQuery.
They can look at
billing reports.
They can do
absolutely everything
you can do on a billing
account, but they will not
be able to go and actually
use resources, see resources,
change settings in projects
because those worlds are split.
That's a very
intentional choice.
There are other roles
on billing accounts that
offer fewer
permissions, the ability
to create them and
view them, but not
to have that level of
administrative control.
There are a couple
of best practices
once you start to think
about this kind of larger
organization billing.
One of them is parent
your billing accounts
in your organization
just like projects.
It's not required, but
it's a good practice
to do so you get
that central control
over the roles on you're
building accounts, too.
Put all your projects
in your organization,
especially if you're
in transition.
And remove the billing account
creator role from your org.
For the vast majority
of customers,
one billing account is
the only billing account
you'll ever need.
A billing account corresponds
to a single invoice
in a single currency, and most
customers are fine with one.
Some very large customers or
customers with special needs
will have multiple
billing accounts.
They might operate in
multiple currencies.
They might have a complex
jurisdictional situation
or departments that really want
their own separate invoice.
And in that case, they'll stray
and have multiple invoices,
multiple billing accounts.
But one is typically
good enough.
Once you take that creator role
away, anyone creating a project
will always land that
project in the org,
and it will always be funded
by your org's single billing
account.
So from a governance
perspective, you're covered.
As I mentioned,
fewer are better.
And a couple of
advanced scenarios
why you might stray into having
multiple billing accounts.
And I'm happy to answer
questions about that
if you have questions about
whether that's right for you
and right for your company.
There's a session which
I'll show on a slide
later on the schedule,
CST200, which
talks about a level above--
in the Google
world-- above cloud,
and how your organization
and its domain
relate to some other things
outside the Google Cloud world.
You might have an Ads account.
You might be paying for G Suite.
There's a separate
payments profile
that lives above Cloud that
spans all of those products.
And if you're an administrator
of an organization, especially
a large organization, or have
a controllership or governance
kind of concern, this is
probably an interesting session
for you, and I'll
show you where that
is in the schedule in a moment.
Last best practice.
Everyone in cloud,
every customer
from the smallest
to the largest,
get free Cloud Billing support.
We have a wonderful
support team that is here
to help with billing questions.
We recognize that
billing can be stressful.
And it's really,
really important
that we answer your
questions, solve the concerns
and problems you have.
So please always feel
free to reach out.
There are links throughout
the Cloud Console
that lets you click through
and get a question answered
by our dedicated billing team.
You can grant that billing team
access to your BigQuery billing
export, and they
will be very thankful
if you do that if you have
a really gnarly question,
because they'll
be able to go look
at that same super high
granularity billing
data that you see,
and help reason
about questions and concerns.
So in summary, enable BigQuery
billing export on day one.
It's almost zero cost.
We give you 10 gigs
of BigQuery for free.
It's $0.02 a gig after that.
You're going to be a pretty
large customer before you have
gigs of billing export data.
That'll be the last
cost you notice.
So turn that on day one.
Use projects to enforce the
boundaries between teams,
or workloads, or
sensitive contexts
within your applications.
And those will be reflected
in your billing data
at that project level.
When you're trying
to answer why,
go first to cost reporting tools
and second to your invoice.
Invoice is how much you owe.
Cost reporting lets you do
that slicing and dicing.
Organizations are for everyone.
Identity as a service is free.
We encourage you to use it,
associate it with your domain,
and get that level of policy
and control of the top level
from day one.
Use folders to
mirror how you work.
A project can only
live in one, so think
about that as the primary key.
And then supercharge
your reporting
by adding labels that cross-cut
across resources and across
projects to get that
extra level of detail.
And finally, Cloud Billing
Support is here to help.
Please reach out.
They'd love to
field your questions
and help with billing concerns.
There are four other
sessions that I'll point out.
There are 12 cost management
sessions happening at Next,
but there are four that
I think are particularly
interesting for this audience as
a deeper dive into these tools
and into real customer data.
CST202, which is
Better Insight--
Measuring the Cost of an
Application on GCP [? as ?]
[? target. ?] We'll be diving in
with some other billing product
managers.
That's today at 2:20.
CST200 is going up
a level, and looking
at how your organization
and your billing accounts
relate in the bigger
picture, how to think
about governance and control.
CST201 on Wednesday afternoon is
a financial governance session,
looking at budgets and alerts,
a feature we haven't really
talked about.
But there's a full
set of budgeting APIs
and alert APIs that lets you
set thresholds in your projects.
And finally, on Thursday,
another customer deep dive,
Beyond your Bill--
Getting more Detail into Cost.
Look at more detail on an actual
customer example of BigQuery,
Data Studio, and how to slice
and dice with real data.
These are all linked off
of cloud.google.com/cost
management, as well.
And these slides will be
available for your review
later on.
All right, that's
the end of our time.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
Enjoy the rest of Next.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]